Nas últimas semanas, a comunidade aqui
do canal cresceu muito e eu senti que já
era hora de dar um passo adiante para
quem quer ir além da informação
superficial e realmente entender a
ciência por trás da medicina funcional.
Então eu criei um novo nível, estudos
avançados do Clube de Canais, exatamente
para isso. Nele eu compartilho aulas
exclusivas a cada 15 dias, onde analiso
estudos recentes, mostro que há de novo
na literatura científica e explico como
aplicar esse conhecimento no dia a dia
clínico e pessoal. Quem faz parte desse
grupo também tem o nome citado no
agradecimentos dos vídeos e passa a
integrar um espaço tudo contínuo
dedicado a quem acompanha a evolução
real da medicina funcional por mente
aberta, razão e propósito. Se você quer
estar por dentro das descobertas mais
recentes e fazer parte dessa comunidade
que estuda e cresce junto, clique aqui,
seja membro logo abaixo e venha pros
estudos avançados. É um espaço feito
para quem busca conhecimento com
profundidade e propósito. Te espero lá.